from dawn till dusk since last autumn up
to 300 trucks a day arrive at this
garbage dump in the city of Kelowna
about 100 kilometers southeast of moscow
the snow covered piles of refuse contain
street car batteries
paint cans and car tires a lot of local
residents say the situation is out of
control and they're worried Iranian
Americana has put together a group
that's trying to limit the environmental
damage
Thank You Marcy no longer a photographer
by emergency architect I was afflicted
up for duty Kings
I can't listen ta cos we've had flicked
at inner fire from suraíh naas obesity
high def alison the fear gives us not
Nick and Melania foolish to interfere
here what is Cosette's off the botton
the residents don't get much help from
local politicians the garbage dump is a
major source of pollution and poses a
serious health threat but Russians know
that it's difficult to try to fight the
authorities arena and her family live in
this two room apartment she hasn't had
much time for her family recently
because she's been working with her
protest group arenas mother helps out
I'm doing all this for my family
and especially for my daughter we bought
this apartment because there's a nice
view of the fields and the air is clean
but now they're trying to take that away
from us Reina is concerned that the
garbage dump will keep growing it's
easier for Moscow to dump its refuse
here than to deal with it there these
are the offices of the local officials
the people of Kelowna are not allowed to
choose their mayor the current
administrator was appointed in 2016 by
the regional governor the garbage
disposal issue has been exaggerated and
politicized by a local group they're
trying to influence the opinions of
local residents in a negative way and we
simply can't allow that
in fact we won't allow the post came a
few days later more than a thousand
people protested the expansion of the
garbage dump the authorities in Moscow
make the decisions we try to tell them
about this mess
but they won't listen it's like you're
sitting at home and one of your
neighbors drops off a load of garbage
and there's nothing you can do about it
you have to complain and write to them
and say that we're not going to put up
with this here the email addresses of
all the city officials we don't want
Moscow's garbage here going to be like
in a summer it's just three kilometers
away the garbage trucks come and go all
day it's awful the demonstration breaks
up after about three hours a number of
people had addressed the crowd
some residents brought friends and
family members including children
afterward the protest organizers meet
relieved that the police didn't turn up
to arrest the demonstrators there were a
lot of people we collected signatures on
a petition aimed at blocking the
expansion of the garbage dump the police
even supported us I thought it all went
quite well
the mayor has now agreed to meet with
arena and other members of the group but
the activists promised they will
continue their fight